and now on to an eyewitness a student
who is at Stoneman Douglas as this
horrific event unfolded David Hogg is
joining us now from Broward County David
first of all you know our our thoughts
are you thoughts and prayers sound after
a while like very trite and cliché but
as I was in my kitchen watching this
today and I have three kids I you just
want to break down and cry but there's
so much bravery on the part of students
and teachers including according to
reports at least one who died it's that
that that does give us some hope in
humanity but tell us what happened and
what you heard unfold as you were in
school today so the first thing that I
heard was one single gunshot we
initially thought it was a drill but it
turned out to be anything but after we
heard the first gunshot we started
heading down the way because the
presumed fire the person that was
shooting up the school pulled the fire
alarm to get more soft targets and so we
started heading towards our designated
zone for the fire anyways on our way
there we started seeing a bunch of
people running and we started running
with those people in the opposite
direction but little did we know at the
time we were actually running towards
the school shooter but luckily for the
heroic actions of one janitor and
actually chef hearth we they saved
hundreds of lives today because they
stopped all the students and got them in
one single room and helped save all of
our lives
there were easily 30 to 40 people in one
single room packed together for an
hour-ish and because of their actions
they saved and there are they okay David
yes right now as far as I know when we
left they were okay I haven't heard
anything otherwise but all the students
are fine and David you're a student
journalist in your writing in school and
which is incredibly helpful because
you're observing everything did you know
the shooter and if you did not do you
know people who knew him and what were
their observations about him
yes I did not know this shooter
personally but I know many people that
did know him what they have said what
I've heard about him is that he was a
person that was very off set kind of
awkward
many people have interesting stories
about him that were really quite awkward
from their time in middle school which
was at the school next door at West
glades middle and just a really
precarious like kind of you know office
guy did you know anything about his
family did they say anything about his
he's upbringing other siblings problems
at home or is he just a social pariah
nobody talked to him and he was really
isolated as far as I know this man was a
very isolated person socially he did not
interact with many people i from what
I've heard from a few of my fellow
students he seemed to have a somewhat
messed up personal life at home he had a
rough personal life and that's as far as
I know and I've heard that from multiple
people there were other reports David
that he had threatened at least kind of
jokingly that I could take I could take
all of your honor I could take some of
you out and they he knew obviously the
layout of the school he knew the drills
the evacuation drills he was up on that
third floor when the alarm was sold he
pulled the alarm so he knew the layout
he knew where people would have to go
correct exactly and the amazing thing is
because because of the heroic and Walt
more-or-less for the actions taken by
the Broward County Schools to make it a
more safe school in the past months in
response to all these mass shootings at
schools that we shouldn't have to deal
with but sadly do they've trained all of
the teachers recently to lock all of the
doors and make sure in case a horrible
horrifying incident like this happens
we're as safe as we can be in luckily
because of those actions I think that
that training saved hundreds of lives
today if not quizes well are there any
school officials or other than like
maybe security or who who are armed
inside the school that you know of as
far as I know
there is a school resource officer that
I believe is armed but I didn't hear
much about him or anything that he did
during this event obviously I'm sure
he's doing all he could but as far as I
know that I haven't heard much about him
but I'm sure the media knows more than I
do tell us about that gazebo area where
certain kids sit in the lunchroom it was
called Owens gazebo or something like
that was kind of the some of the
outcasts it I was reading about that
that he he wasn't even welcome in that
area where kind of some of the you know
that was again it's in social media but
some of the freaks in school sit because
they're not accepted in the rest of the
school tell me about that yeah it's so
he sat in an area that sadly many
students refer to as I'm not gonna say
it on TV but it's an area we're very
unique kids like sit and children that
are interested in things that are more
like extracurricular and outside it's
going to have amazing interest and her
just as valuable as any other student at
this school they're just unique
individuals that have interesting
aspirations but the fact that he was out
casted by those people I would say it it
doesn't say a lot but it actually it
does say a lot because here at Stone at
some in Douglas high school we like to
accept everyone for who they are we like
to bring everyone in and just embrace
who they are and sadly with this person
he didn't feel that way he didn't feel
accepted and that may have been part of
the reason why he did this horrible
atrocity that should never happen
isolated isolated in one case they he
described himself as being bullied did
you hear anything about that that he was
bullied by one particular individual and
that he was gonna get him did you hear
anything about that I haven't heard
anything about bullying but I can tell
you that um from what I've heard he does
seem like an individual that um would
have had a rough time in school based
off of a some of his previous actions
like just interesting and weird comments
made to people like around him certain
students even one of his tutors that um
yeah just what was the castings David
what was the calming yeah what was that
comment
it was actually
I don't want to go on this person told
me not to tell anyone if I you don't
have to identify anybody but what was
the comment don't identify the name but
what would What did he say
the comment was a the comment was a
request for sexual relations with a
student hmm
and it was very awkward according to
them yeah and obviously we're probably
obviously rejected so David incredibly
poised informative information tonight
and our our emotions that's a good thing
to the audience yes yeah okay I don't
want this to be another mass shooting I
don't want this just to be something
that people forget this is something
that people need to look at and realize
that there is a serious issue in this
country that we all need to face it's an
issue that affects each and every one of
us and if you think it doesn't believe
me it will especially if we don't take
action to step up and stop things like
that for example you and your
congressman and asking them for help and
doing things like that David thank you
so much we really appreciate your words
tonight and our prayers are with all of
you and your family and the schoolmates
and all of those who've lost their lives
tonight